neues elementarteilchen entdeckt das
geschieht wirklich nicht alle tage im
all age ii dem large hadron collider am
cern in genf in der schweiz wurde ein
neues elementarteilchen entdeckt im
größten teilchenbeschleuniger der welt
er ist 26,7 kilometer lang wurde das
neue teilchen c c c++ am alex i beat
detector entdeckt zum einen vermuteten
die forscher und forscherinnen ein
solches zahlt ihnen zum anderen hat es
aber seltsame eigenschaften an solche
zeichen wurde bisher noch nicht gefunden
jetzt den kriegs und science fiction
herzlich willkommen als ich noch klein
war und es ist eine ganz weile her da
galt noch ein ziemlich einfaches
teilchen modellen da gab es den atomkern
mit dem proton und neutron und darum
kreisten elektronen doch schon sehr bald
danach stellte sich heraus ganz so
einfach ist es nicht dabei gab es die
idee was unsere welt aus ganz kleinen
teilchen besteht also atomen schon in
der antike
doch es war ein reines denken und es gab
keinerlei möglichkeit ihre existenz
mittelbar oder unmittelbar zu beweisen
erst 1905 gab na wer wohl
albert eckstein den entscheidenden
anstoß er erklärte die brownsche
bewegung als durch zufällige stöße von
atomen oder molekülen verursachte um
diese zeit herum also früher und auch
später wurden dann auch elektronen
protonen neutronen vorhergesagt und
entdeckt sie galten dann bis in die 60er
jahre als kleinste teilchen dann aber
sagten verschiedene physiker die quarks
als kleinste teilchen voraus nur durch
sie waren verschiedene phänomene
erklärbar und im laufe der zeit wurden
immer mehr quarks arten vorhergesagt und
auch gefunden die teilchenphysik wurde
dadurch zu einem sehr spannenden
forschungsfeld könnte sie doch
irgendwann einmal die welt wirklich
erklären inzwischen gibt es einen
riesigen teilchen zu der an den immer
größer gewordenen teilchenbeschleunigern
entdeckt wurde da gibt es keinen wohnen
lebt ohne barrieren und so weiter und so
fort ein wirklicher zu an teilchen und
jetzt gibt es wieder ein neues am alex
ii ist man auf dem weg zu einer
möglichen erklärung der welt einen
schritt weiter gekommen jetzt wurde das
c c c++ entdeckt und dieses teilchen
existierte nur für 0,00 null
000 000 000 5 sekunden also wirklich nur
für einen bruchteil einer sekunde es ist
ein baron und gehört damit zu den
teilchen die am meisten vorkommen wie zb
protonen und neutronen die beiden
teilchen atomkern es entstand als die
forscher und forscherinnen protonen
aufeinander schossen es verriet sich in
diesem moment als es zerfiel zwar waren
solche teilchen vorhergesagt aber noch
nie gefunden worden ist trägt nämlich
zwei schwere charme quarks und ein
leichtes ab quarks in sich mit diesem
teilchen erhoffen sich die physiker und
physikerinnen bald neue erkenntnisse
über die starke kernkraft die zb den
atomkern zusammenhält das besondere an
diesen drei quarks ist nämlich dass sie
nicht wie bei anderen teilchen einen
komplexen tanz vollführen sondern sich
wie ein doppelsternsystem mit einem
planeten verhalten ihr tanz dürfte also
viel einfacher sein und deshalb
womöglich neue erkenntnisse über die
starke kernkraft liefern das lg wird
also in zukunft noch eine menge
bahnbrechende erkenntnisse liefern wenn
ihr keine davon verpassen wollt dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den auf die glocke hier
geht es weiter mit hinweis auf
asymmetrie bei antimaterie auch ein
ziemlich spannendes thema wenn es euch
interessiert dann klickt unbedingt drauf
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran